quella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
questo video sono faringei pedaggi siamo
su inside che praticamente allora per
chi avesse a massimo già partiti così ma
sul serio
ma cosa niente ragazzi sono già partiti
va bene praticamente non so se conoscete
limbo limbo videogame dagli stessi
creatori di inside che era famosissima
ai tempi per essere un gioco indie che
questo videogame è molto ma molto simile
siamo un ragazzino senza faccia è una
nuova serie che volevo iniziare perché
avevo adorato tantissimo limbo a suo
tempo quindi credo che ad orero anche
questo poi non si sa mai però penso che
sia una figata da solo a vedere come
fatto sono questo ragazzino che si e
sperduto nella foresta non si sa come
non si sa perché scavalco massimi che a
reggio chi cazzo
c'è nella gente nei camion che è
successo
oddio mi investe ma c'è un k c'è altra
gente come cazzo fai se c'è altra gente
che strano caso ero convinto che fosse
un videogame tipo tipo limbo dove
prevede sei da solo per tutto il
videogame
vabbè ragazzi proseguiamo forte sega del
camion non ho capito perché chi storia
c'è della gente ragano fermi non ci
posso credere
sono abituato a lì perché hanno delle
maschere si dice addio lavoro mi guardi
qua settete focato cazzo cazzo marito
l'ha visto l'ha visto e stuprato cosa
succederà sta succedendo lì dietro non
lo voglio sapere
va bè ragazzi ci ho provato l'importante
è provarci voi adesso ripartito da qua e
come cazzo faccia scappare da strati zio
magari prova a non saltare come un ebete
come prima ma se corro ok ami chiara era
era più semplice del previsto ragazzi
bastava stare fermi non ho capito perché
i tizi hanno una maschera prova ve lo
scopriremo cosa me ne faccio di un ferma
possa afferrare gli oggetti fare
qualcosa che cazzo me ne faccio di un
frigo ma devo lo scemo io mi chiamo come
fatta male
arci allora io di saltare su sta minchia
di frigo perfetto non era così difficile
cosa non fare che cosa qui camion che
un'ora che sta portando gente tra
l'altro dentro non ho capito
vabbè tanto non mi possono vedere ma io
chi sono perché sono qua spiegate
qualcosa è una figata se pian piano si
entra nell'ottica di gioco ma io sto
scappando da qualche parte si va a
quello che ho capito finora ne ha visto
veloce veloce c'è qualcuno c'è un cane
che cazzo corri cosa di deficiente
corriere sono vivo
non è vero sono io non ci posso credere
che corre pardòn cane del cazzo e il
problema non è quello il problema è che
adesso mi hanno avvistato mi devo
correre mai veloce veloce che figata
e bellissimo vita mi ha messo un
adrenalina epica sto pezzo fantastico
probabilmente eravamo rinchiusi in
questo edificio strano ci hanno portati
via e io sono riuscito a fuggire
questo coloro capito credo è poi magari
non è così sicuramente più avanti sarà
molto più chiaro
[ __ ] perché hanno una maschera merda
merda merda
sotto sotto sotto sotto che culo ce l'ho
fatta non mi ha visto
non ci credo mai sono riuscito a
sfuggire lì così veramente fenomeno
della mimetizzazione ragazzi epico che
c'e la macchina fermi fermi che succede
posso come passo mi piaceva ma poco qua
si è fermata è che culo che faccio devo
correre corri corri merda lo sapevo lo
sapevo
corri corri corri cari voce tv che
saltano a volte parte di miche sull
travolge parte di mica posso saltare
anche parte veloce e vabbè minchia
pezzi di merda ma lo sparato ma
veramente non è ma che che chi quante
violento sto gioco per ragazzi
riproviamoci deve essere abbastanza
incasinato perché non ho visto nessun
punto dove nascondermi non so dove amaci
qua un camper centrocampo e dentro
cambia dentro camper vai vai vai veloce
la cella c'è la cena ed ai che la cosa
mi sta facendo il tasto mi ha strozzato
ma maledizione dietro stayen con serietà
un attimo come passa vado subito dai
cori ma mi sparare nomi sparare nomi
sparare sono eva per inciampato ma che
sfiga
quanto è difficile sta parte dai mi
[Applauso]
chiami spara con mista me lo sento mi
spara non sento non mi ha sparato ai
cori io vivo solivo non si buttava che
sono cagasotto mi hanno sparato ma mi
hanno mancato fantastico ai zio corrie e
vabbè ma mi citava chi cazzo sono un
ladro ma come quanto lo fu fate quanto
che colore c'è stata una andata di culo
che c'era l'acqua sotto se non mi
schianta vaud per terra e ho detto
ragazzi date centa io però è mica c'è
chi m'ha preso ma 3 ma cosa ma se è un
chilometro come ha fatto a prendermi
ma cosa vogliono da me posso andare
sott'acqua
ah ok mi chiamo l'arena semplice
mi spiegate come mai mi sparano
addirittura c'è cosa ho fatto di strano
non ho capito possa emergere perfetto
prima o poi finirà la gente prego iddio
per lì sì perché in casa non vada avanti
così a vita ciò è assurdo che sono dei
porci perché c'è un maiale per terra che
è successo ho scoperto la fabbrica
segreta di di buste e quelli sono vegani
chi vogliono uccidere i vegani vegano
infame per te solo salame e vabbè mica
pensato di sfracellarsi che lo
strapiombo invece la basso va bene credo
spero spero iddio che si sia calmata la
situa perché non è possibile aprire
porte in modo alternativo fa figo non
fare mai parkour zio è perché ti vedo ma
le due parti proprio di merda vabbè
tanto quanto minchia sono al triste
pannocchie
che cos'è sta roba o sono io che son
mano fatemi capire di qua una balla di
fieno ok dovremmo essere abbastanza
sicuro perché non c'è nessuno così
prova sono pulcini mi sembra incredibile
avere così tanta tranquillità è assurdo
perché mi spiegate perchè ci sono dei
maiali morti at
così è successo ci sono i pulcini cos'è
sta roba
posso entrare permesso tiro la leva anno
mi arrampico una potenza la porta susa
hanno la porta è chiusa va bene levatevi
pulcini devo fare indiana jones a
trattare fa chi era
pensiamo c'è una leva per non saper né
leggere né scrivere io la tiro non
funzionano cazzo a devo prima attivare
generatore giustamente a faccio grazie
del generatore con questo ci carico
l'iphone ha funzionato perché tira la
leva
cosa serve sta roba
ma dovrebbe spingere giù la balla di
fieno vere tipo fa dietro c'è la porta
ma no non è togliere la barricata che se
non entra gente vabbè dai scusate
ragazzi non volevo o spaventato tutti i
pulcini entrate datemi una mano che non
ho capito come funziona credo che loro
sappiano voi che siete superti in
ingegneria meccanica allora io tiro
questa leva e non funziona ecco brava
fate voi è una leva e tranquilli non ho
la leva alla leva la leva cagate la però
devo fare qualcosa sicuramente a meno
che non mi spingano loro qua non ci
arrivo quindi non ho capito cosa devo
fare
va bene cosa grazie ragazzi scusate se
vi ho usati però non volevo neanche
perdonate la mia maleducazione però
almeno posso andare avanti grazie siete
stati molto utili ragazzi e nei
videogiochi servono i pulcini può
vedermi denunciano dal vvf per
maltrattamento di pulcini e cos'è sta
roba
no no no kat non è come assassin's creed
non puoi farlo tu zio non è che dei
porci morti attutiscono una caduta però
io ci provo jolo suo morto come ma cosa
ma con la fisica tutta sua sto gioco
provate a dire i pompieri invece di
prendere il tappeto con l'elastico per
tutti
prendete propri porci morti funziona
visto gioco sfruttato più animali che
altro non ho capito perché vabbè via
perché siamo così una fattoria questa no
per forza un altro porco morto se
faranno mai inside 2 sarà la vendetta
dei porci viventi faccio erogata una
scimmia proprio perfetto chiama come nel
fango che si è proprio lì dove vi
infilarti zio c'è dio mio almeno
magnelli la faccia non va beh lasciamo
perdere
vorrei vedere voi con un buco nel culo
che cazzo vuoi non sto soltanto come se
niente fosse
sono un fenomeno mica torero sono bravo
e me la cavo
c'è ovviamente devo avanzare tentando di
non farmi incornare che poi non ha le
corna il maiale ma che cazzo vuole da me
hai un bruco nel culo fai quello che
vuoi ma non tornarmi qual è il tuo
problema non gli faccio sfondare il muro
non pensavo così tanto addirittura c'è
gente ciao gente
vorrei venire a salutarvi e a
presentarmi croce un maiale che sta
tentando di stuprare milan ora e mezza
veniva me sta facendo questi mi scusi
lei che prega mi dà una mano che c'è un
porco che un ora che sta tentando di
incornare mi no niente a posto e morto
ho sentito io devo no no no non fare
queste cose ho veramente visto quello
che ho appena visto ho appena tolto un
hayter dal culo di un porco tutto a
posto e zio tutto a posto vai tranquillo
ma tin gruppo io adesso lo posso
spostare a mio piacimento ma cosa senti
zio scusa non è che ti sto in gruppo
andò robe prodotto sposarvi qualche devo
raggiungere grazie stai fermo è staccato
ragazzi questa era la prima parte di
inside fatemi sapere nei commenti se
volete che io l'ho continui tanto lo
continuo stesso perché mi piace cave a
farti skate ragazzi spero vi piace
perché veramente veramente figo secondo
me sei video è piaciuto molto il calcio
documento è un mi piace anche a pagina
di facebook e come vi ho dato notizia
nei sensori di dischetti ci vediamo al
prossimo video dai ragazzi
[Musica]